i understand you were just in new york
city how was it new york how did it go
it was great it was uh it was a lot of
fun i was staying on the east side which
i love
and then went to see a friend
a friend one day on the west side he
said come on come on over and i didn't
realize it was gay pride day it was it
was it was it was like
150 000 men
all very excited i have to be wearing it
tank top because it was hot out you're
you're wearing a tank top i was yeah
typical shorts
you were wearing a big mustache just
because it was hot
you know
and then i got uh chased down the street
by uh a large got chased down the street
by a large man wearing a sock around his
uh
really
so wait let's check shouting
[Applause]
you're quite welcome to the city i i
think i made it back to the hotel in 12
minutes yeah that's so fascinating first
of all that the guys out just wearing a
socks yeah sees you and then just has
the confidence to just go running after
you
can it was just like
whoa
and by confidence you mean confidence in
the sock